I couldn't sleep last night
and realized that I had a head of Napa cabbage in the fridge
and hadn't made kimchi in a while.
So I decided to go downstairs and do exactly that.
I cut my cabbage into quarters
and took the core out before slicing it into smaller pieces,
repeated that with each quarter and put them in a large bowl,
sprinkle them with salt, massage my cabbage,
and then topped it with water.
I put a plate on top to make it a little heavier
and then let that sit for about two hours.
After about two hours,
I poured all that water out and rinsed it a couple times
before letting it sit in my strainer
while I prep my marinade. I grated some garlic, ginger,
put that back in the bowl with some fish sauce,
sprinkle of sugar, and some red chili flakes for giving that a good mix.
While that was sitting and getting to know each other,
I peeled my daikon radish and sliced it into matchsticks
before moving on to cutting up some spring onions.
Once all my prep was done,
I put all of my vegetables into my large bowl,
started mixing that really well,
making sure to get everything coated evenly.
I then started filling it into my jar.
I had to try a little bit just to make sure it was perfect.
Then I screwed the lid on
and let it stand for four days at room temperature. To ferment